Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Ho iniziato a insegnare disegno
per raccontare alle persone
tutto quello che il disegno
ha insegnato a me,
nell'arco della vita, sulla vita.
Sono qui per dirvi che saper disegnare
è qualcosa che va ben oltre
il fare un bel disegno.
Il disegno è una porta
verso la conoscenza
di sé stessi e del mondo
ed è anche un linguaggio infinito,
illimitato, alla portata di tutti.
Il tema di oggi è "Tornare a crederci".
Io vorrei invitarvi a tornare a credere
alla possibilità
di meravigliarvi di voi stessi.
Magari, perché no, attraverso il disegno.
Perché questo?
Perché le parole degli altri
a volte ci frenano.
Quante volte, magari,
abbiamo sentito dire,
quando eravamo piccoli
o, perché no, anche da adulti,
che disegnare è una cosa stupida,
o è un'attività inutile
che non può essere un lavoro.
E quante volte ci siamo sentiti dire
la frase, 'Non sei capace',
non necessariamente
nell'ambito del disegno.
Come ho detto prima,
le parole degli altri frenano,
le paure degli altri frenano.
E ci portano spesso a prendere binari
che sono molto lontani
dai nostri veri desideri.
Il disegno, nella pratica continua,
ci mostra come sia possibile
superare noi stessi,
superare le nostre stesse aspettative
per raggiungere dei risultati
che sono sconvolgenti,
ci fanno meravigliare.
E quindi il disegno rimane
una grandissima metafora
di quella che può essere
la nostra esperienza di vita.
Questi sono disegni
di alcuni miei allievi.
I miei allievi vanno
dai 13 anni ai 70 anni.
Ed è bellissimo vedere
come una persona
intraprende un percorso
e si meraviglia del suo cambiamento.
Parlando di disegno, però,
dobbiamo parlare delle sue
componenti fondamentali.
Il segno.
Il segno è dato dal movimento
e dallo strumento.
Il segno racconta il nostro carattere,
racconta il modo in cui noi agiamo,
non solo sulla carta ma anche nella vita.
E poi c'è la visione,
ovvero il modo in cui
noi vediamo la realtà
che si traduce sulla carta
nel modo in cui noi
la rappresentiamo.
Segno e visione insieme, nella pratica,
vanno a stimolare il sistema nervoso.
Cosa significa?
Che il sistema nervoso
diventa più ricettivo,
si apre, si espande.
Quindi diventiamo più sensibili,
più capaci di percepire
le sottigliezze, i dettagli.
Questa cosa incide tantissimo
sul risultato, chiaramente,
ma incide anche
sulla nostra consapevolezza,
quindi sulla nostra autostima;
e così via, ciclicamente.
Perché il disegno migliora nel tempo,
e continua a migliorare,
e continua a farci meravigliare.
Kimon Nicolaïdes,
le cui parole sono state riportate
nel libro "Disegnare in modo naturale",
sosteneva che c'è una grande differenza
tra il saper disegnare
e il fare disegni.
Il disegno in quanto oggetto
è una dimostrazione, è un risultato.
Attesta un successo,
ed è ciò che tutti si aspettano.
Ma ciò che conta veramente
è quel percorso meraviglioso
che ci conduce ad affinare
la nostra consapevolezza
nei confronti della vita,
quindi cambia il nostro modo di osservare
e di vivere la vita nel disegnare.
Parlando di cose concrete,
il disegno, quindi,
migliora il nostro modo
di vedere la realtà così com’è.
Migliora la nostra capacità
di utilizzare il corpo e il movimento
in modo funzionale.
Ci dà la capacità di sintesi,
ovvero di trovare
nella realtà l'essenziale.
Però fa bene anche alla progettazione.
Cosa significa?
Noi possiamo partire
da una realtà preesistente,
[ed] elaborarla
per generare una nuova realtà.
Fa bene a pazienza, memoria e attenzione.
Ci insegna la dedizione
e ci insegna anche la determinazione.
Ecco perché mi piace insegnare disegno
soprattutto agli adulti.
Perché è bellissimo vedere
quando un adulto decide
di intraprendere un viaggio
che non è un viaggio soltanto esterno,
è un viaggio dentro di sé.
E decide di scoprire
dei nuovi aspetti di sé.
Il disegno fa emergere talenti
che non sono necessariamente
legati all'arte visiva.
Fa sorprendere, perché apre delle porte
che fino ad allora erano rimaste chiuse.
Quindi medici, avvocati, ingegneri,
anche gli architetti, che al giorno d'oggi
disegnano pochissimo,
possono imparare a disegnare
per imparare a progettare
spazi e processi,
per imparare a trovare soluzioni
attraverso un pensiero
che è un pensiero visivo.
Possono imparare a usare la loro mente
in un modo molto diverso
rispetto a come la mente
lavora nel quotidiano.
Ma il disegno è anche terapia,
nel senso che può aiutare persone
che hanno difficoltà ad esempio motorie.
Oppure persone che hanno difficoltà
di dislessia o disgrafia,
ma anche accompagnare persone
che stanno seguendo una cura
o un percorso di
riabilitazione, una terapia.
Perché il disegno
può essere anche raccontato così.
È uno spazio, senza spazio e senza tempo,
tra due parentesi nel percorso della vita.
In quell'istante, l'istante
della pratica del disegno,
la persona mette da parte il suo io
e si fonde con l'esistenza.
In quel momento
c'è solo esistenza e creazione.
Quindi la persona si apre
molto più facilmente al cambiamento.
Quindi le arti, per me,
sono un luogo speciale
e vorrei che fossero
un luogo speciale per tutti.
Il luogo per conoscersi,
senza necessariamente
farne una professione.
Per me sono uno spazio carico di dignità
che tutti dovrebbero
imparare a comprendere,
e accettare in questo senso.
Dagli adulti ai bambini,
ma dico soprattutto agli adulti,
perché sono gli adulti che poi
accompagnano i bambini nel loro percorso,
prendono delle decisioni per loro.
Per cui il mio invito
è quello di tornare a casa
con una visione diversa
di ciò che è il disegno,
di ciò che sono le arti.
E se Nicolaïdes sosteneva
che l’intangibile
è più interessante del tangibile
e che anche il percorso conta
quanto la meta, quanto il risultato,
allora il disegno
può essere anche qualcos'altro.
Può staccarsi da ciò
che è rappresentazione
per farsi puro segno,
per diventare performance.
Qualcosa che racconti
un'azione, un'esperienza,
quindi una sorta di mappa
che racconta un istante di esperienza.
Lui è Paolo Gozzetti e stiamo…
(Applausi)
Ora andremo a raccontarvi qualcosa.
Grazie.
(Applausi)